é bom eu queria falar aqui de de
economia de emoção eu quem me conhece
sabe que eu sou muito emoção e muito
pouca economia de um modo geral mas o
ponto é que a emoção vem a ser a nossa
próxima o futuro para alguns já é hoje a
moeda de troca para tudo isso seja a
nível pessoal profissional é e eu acho
que é realmente isso a gente chega hoje
um estudo que já diz que 80% das nossas
decisões qualquer país seja são feitas
pela emoção
isso é muito importante considerar com
qualquer projeto que a gente for abordar
mas para poder falar para eu poder falar
aqui sobre economia de emoção
conversando com a nossa curadora já
foram começados começo falar um pouco do
que você faz para explicar como é que se
chegou e e ea basicamente há seis anos
atrás eu fiz uma mudança quase radical e
sair do mundo da moda das imagens da
tendência aquela que aparece na revista
que um pouco vulgar usou a palavra e
comecei a trabalhar com uma empresa de
previsão de tendências a onde a gente lá
busca entender quais são os desejos dos
consumidores e não o que a gente quer
vender para eles o que eles querem
pessoas que a gente deseja todos nós
aqui então eu comecei a descobrir que
isso existia e que todos nós somos
capazes de fazer isso a gente começar a
ligar os pontos e volta da gente então
pra ficar claro a gente vai fazer um
exercício de economia de emoção juntos
para vocês entenderem o processo um
pouco melhor
é um processo que começa com uma
curiosidade incessante eu sou curiosa
aquelas que nunca saiu da fase do porquê
porque disso porque daqui e é uma coisa
que eu incentivo estilo em todo mundo
que eu conheço a gente tem que ter essa
curiosidade não de memorizar wikipedia
como apareceu ali mas de tentar entender
o porquê das coisas as motivações mais
profundas que a gente tem que fazer cada
uma das nossas decisões
então a gente é nessa onde eu trabalho
claire chama a gente desenvolver essas
oito dinâmicas pela qual a gente filtra
porque imaginem que a gente pesquisou o
ano inteiro o tempo inteiro de tudo
quanto é fonte
então aqui a gente vai ver coisas mais
da cultura pop digamos assim mas é uma
investigação que passa vários níveis
porque a gente quer ter certeza que a
gente sabe quais são os novos modelos
que quer dizer em termos de identidade o
que o hedonismo ele quer dizer a gente
sabe que a gente só faz coisas o prazer
hoje em dia a gente se entender como é
que é isso se manifesta saber a
revolução colaborativa é um é uma
dinâmica interessante porque a há cinco
anos atrás era uma novidade é uma
tendência da evolução colaborativa
hoje a gente sabe que para os jovens os
mais jovens da geração z
aí não é questão de ter uma empresa ou
um trabalho sem essa colaboratividade
sem pensar no outro sem pensar na
comunidades já não é mais uma questão já
é um valor que se estabilizou digamos a
nova ordem global que seja quem são as
novas influências estéticas ou economias
enfim como é que o mundo está se
comportando né nesse sentido o nosso
relacionamento com a natureza mas também
com a nossa própria natureza porque a
gente está finalmente chegando naquele
momento que a gente entende que a gente
não é nada sem a natureza natureza tá de
boa sem gente - a gente depende dela
a busca pelo sentido transcendência vou
falar espiritualidade para alguns aí e é
claro que tudo que é relacionamento com
o tempo eo espaço
a questão da celebração à vontade de
desacelerar mas também tudo que tem
teclas ciências desenvolvidas então a
gente pega essas oito valores e usa como
se fosse uma peneira para poder depois
brincar de ligar os pontos
a questão de frisar que tem em seu banco
sem falas 50% intuição 50% metodologia a
metodologia cada uma tem a sua
a gente trabalha com semiótica ou como
os gregos chamavam semiologia o estudo
dos sinais
o estudo dos sinais que nada mais é que
as nossas referências culturais o que a
gente está assistindo lendo ouvindo o
que está acontecendo em volta da gente
que representa cada uma dessas bolinhas
ea gente vai conectar para chegar a
algum tipo de
constato ou alguma tendência digamos
assim ea intuição aquilo que vai vai
deixar a gente seguro que é uma maçã é
uma pena né a gente sabe e e o
interessante da intuição ea gente
trabalha muito menos do que a gente
devia é que ela é bem como um músculo
quanto mais trabalho mas ela fica forte
mas ela fica certeira mas já consegue
conectar esses pontos e chegar a
conclusões que sejam construtivas para
sua vida pessoal profissional tanto faz
e aí aconteceu e se esse esse chamado em
fevereiro 2017
me ligaram falaram olha a gente vai
fazer uma apresentação para apresentar
em nova york para um público livre e eu
testei pânico no lago foi o que eu vou
falar por estados unidos neste momento
com esse contexto com o que está
acontecendo
foi um processo super doído aquele
processo que você vai lá buscar entender
e noites mal dormidas e sonho meu da
noite o que eu ia falar porque realmente
é eu fui perceber depois que esse medo
todo é uma felicidade fazer um trabalho
sem grife sem clientes no final das
contas em que eu podia parar e pensar
que bom que eu gostaria de falar para
essas pessoas ou no caso pra vocês
também que eu posso trazer desse tanto
de coisa que eu pesquiso é eu tenho
prazer trabalhar com uma equipe
maravilhosa de artistas filósofos
escritores assim uma com uma mistura de
pessoas muito muito rica e deu um passo
atrás que o primeiro passo adiante dar
um passo à frente para pensei e analisei
toda a nossa pesquisa ea gente já tinha
começado a falar sobre a importância é
dado que a gente chama de economia dos
afectos ou de emoção dessa questão de
falar com as pessoas através do
emocional buscar fazer essas conexões
porque se a gente entrar num contexto da
juventude de hoje todo mundo cresceu com
crise pós crise pós caos pós dramas e
guerras e problemas e volta gente ea
gente ficou muito desconfiado
ninguém acredita em mais nada não é à
toa que enfim toda a questão da verdade
é uma está em pauta hoje em dia
mas isso fez com que confia se muito
mais na emoção porque nela a gente sabe
que ele está sentindo a gente sabe que
tem uma coisa acontecendo a emoção ela
passa pelo racional não é só aquela
sensação física nem nós nem o sentimento
ela passa por uma então para isso aqui
me fez pensar e sentir dessa forma e
três dinâmicas que que eu identifiquei
que eu puxei construir essa apresentação
vieram e muito muito complementares na
primeira fala de abraçar pluralidade
autêntica ou seja essa questão de a
gente não quer mais ser isso ou aquilo a
gente quer ser isso ou aquilo outro aqui
no outro piloto tudo isso faz parte da
gente não precisa abandonar uma coisa
pela outra ou como como foi falado que
antes virar um título uma coisa que não
é só isso não necessariamente
e quanto mais a gente fala é que os
jovens mais eles acreditam
espontaneidade eles querem falar de alta
expressão eles querem se libertar quem
fala é isso que que vem dessa
autenticidade de algo que seja entre 5 a
segunda dinâmica que é uma dinâmica do
coletivo ea gente vai dar um zoom nela
até o final que vamos falar mais dela
pra mim é mais urgente realmente a gente
entender que todos nós somos capazes de
se reconstruir depois de qualquer tipo
de trauma digamos assim onde qualquer
dificuldade mas é sempre melhor grupo
então a questão da da residência vem com
um pra mim com um peso muito muito muito
forte hoje em dia e por último a questão
da simbiose que fala do planeta que fala
da ética que fala da sustentabilidade
que fala do respeito pela natureza de
entender que essa é a nossa co
dependência nela respeitá lo assim então
é uma dinâmica mais global e essa foi um
pouco a grande pesquisa que nasceu mas
eu vou falar de uma coisa
especificamente eu acho que é justamente
esse pano de que me emociona mais de
todos que essa necessidade de entender o
mundo com mais simpatia de ser mais
tolerantes de ser mais aberto e d
de poder acreditar que a gente vai se
reconstruir justamente como a proposta
aqui né do evento que é vamos como é que
a gente vai construir diferente já que
assim não tá rolando então am
eu esqueci de falar que quem trabalha
com previsão de tendência otimista por
natureza então os pessimistas que a
gente cumpre
porque se a gente não for otimista a
gente não encontra se a luz no fim do
túnel a gente fica um pouco né vesgo em
relação a isso e o legal da questão da
semiótica que você vai encontrando
pequenas gotas de esperança o caminho
então o primeiro aqui é o time ea
diretoria do hashtag taitung ela foi uma
uma ação que aconteceu durante a última
semana de moda de nova york que a abc
nesta festa na plataforma de notícias
estatal resolveu distribuir essas bandas
brancas das pessoas que foi uma
manifestação completamente silenciosa me
falou sobre isso não teve grandes né ela
foi usada na passarela tanto quanto na
platéia pra falar sobre a união dos
laços que unem a gente então há muito
além do que raça nacionalidade religião
gênero enfim qualquer outra qualquer
outra coisa e então essa essa união
feita muito forte
a cry é é uma revista que vai sair agora
em 2017 não deram uma data ainda é uma
revista francesa e é onde ela me
interessa é que o craque quer dizer
costa claro concluiu sua juventude
mestiça e radical feita por jovens ela
mesmo se descreve como uma revista que
quer falar de inspiração e de emoção
porque a gente sabe já que a gente está
vivendo na na geração mais mestiça que
jamais o ea tendência é que isso vá
aumentar que seja isso raça religião
qualquer outra coisa
novas composições de família tanto faixa
então quando você enxerga uma revista
feita por jovens em que você fala pois
só tem uma questão de abertura e as
pessoas estão buscando estão querendo
integrar tão querendo acolher também
abraçar o maior número de pessoas
possíveis que ao contrário não tem a
gente já tá
sabendo que nessa cultura de de
xenofobia que a gente vive hoje em dia
não está funcionando e por isso que eu
peguei um exemplo da amb que todo mundo
conhece que teve aquele boom boom e
vamos fazer o empate com a minha casa e
ficar aqui na minha casa porque aí
passaram se os anos virou modelo de
negócio super comum e aí hoje naquele
momento em que essa é justamente essa
cultura do contra do não do da exclusão
digamos assim
aparece aí eu bebi fala assim não vamos
fazer toda uma função uma ação para
falar como a gente aceita a gente aceita
outro qualquer que seja a o rosto que
ele tiver isso não é o ponto
o ponto é uma briga às nossas casas
vamos abrir os nossos espaços e dividir
o espaço
então a gente fala muito de tolerância
eu tive uma palestra da semana passar no
mês passado
e aí pessoal vai mais tolerância tão
despesar no bairro que eu tolero o outro
é mais tolerar já é uma coisa a gente
consegue tolerar todo mundo já é um
passo muito bom eu acho
daí a depois aceitar que em casa e tal é
outra coisa nós vamos tentar no primeiro
passo é tolerado não gostou de tudo bem
mas nunca num não incomoda
e aí eu queria falar de pharrel williams
néné adorado por muitas pessoas
conhecido por sua excentricidade ele se
une lá adidas para mais uma colaboração
e ele faz uma coleção chamada rio h o
que ele quer com isso falar sobre a
humanidade e o rio que quer dizer cor
também conheço ele defende é o fato que
todos nós deveríamos jogar no mesmo time
afinal independentemente da nossa cor ou
da nossa né nosso rosto ele está ele
traz essa ideia play foi do rio - vamos
todos tentar jogar na mesma direção
torceria para o mesmo time juntos sempre
sucesso de todos que é assim que a gente
vai avançando e vai pra frente e ele fez
isso coincidência ou não é numa reserva
indígena
americano ali onde rola aquele assunto
da costa pai pânico nem vou entrar nele
ainda mas que traz uma outra bagagem
além
ele faz isso de maneira sutil gente não
percebe muito bem o que estão todos
vestidos com a coleção dele e com isso
ele consegue contar é um um negro
americano contando uma história com com
nativos americanos para o mundo sobre
cores e humanidade é de esperança isso
né
e justamente essa questão de identidade
coletiva da gente entender que somos
todos uma coisa só e que a residência
vai feita junto todo mundo junto
então é eu trouxe um ótimo exemplo eu
trouxe um vídeo para ver se emocionando
vocês um pouco também é que pra mim é o
melhor exemplo de como que a empatia
criativa ea economia emocional podem
trazer novas idéias daí de comunicação
de inovação de diálogo dinâmico
minutinhos que prevê atingir no ano
anita e felipe melo eo banco bic em fio
anne 10 mil disse a mãe
estou eu e janet jackson e escrevia ayew
falhas
o ex-líder rock
sei que te pagar e os sons liberar o
jovem josé godoy na aba decidir como vão
sumir da hipnose as cheias a este exame
anual desse tipo na realidade na galé
como disciplinar dentro do setinha já
que o rei já foi professor do esquerdo
atila to bottle tentar acessar ou seja é
uma agência de viagem está o que fez
isso é bom eu deixo vocês com 11 com a
uma das minhas pistas preferidas e
pedindo pra vocês espalhar a emoção por
onde der
o que eu acho que a coisa vai ficar
melhor para todo mundo muito obrigada
[Aplausos]